smart girl mary sue she's learned early
to brush her teeth the right way at the
right time
brush your teeth immediately after
eating if brushing is impossible rinse
the mouth with water
brush the upper teeth downward the lower
teeth upward for healthier teeth
a prettier smile learn to brush your
teeth correctly
good food for good health but for good
dental health what not to eat
is also important dental scientists
report that sugar is the major cause of
tooth decay
avoid candy and other sweet foods
between meals substitute fruit nuts or
popcorn
cut down on sweets cut down on tooth
decay
johnny has a new tooth and an important
one it is
children's first of baby teeth affect
general health they're necessary as a
guide for permanent teeth to follow
for clear speech for giving form and
symmetry to the face
protect your children's first teeth help
your youngster toward lifelong dental
health
smart girl marries you she's learned to
brush her teeth the right way
at the right time brush your teeth
immediately after eating
or rinse the mouth with water brush the
upper teeth downward
the lower teeth upward this is national
children's dental health week your
dentist has learned to brush your teeth
correctly
good food for good health but for good
dental health what not to eat is also
important
dental scientists report that sugar is
the main cause of tooth decay
this is national children's dental
health week you can substitute fruit for
sweet foods between meals
cut down on sweets cut down on tooth
decay
johnny has a new tooth and an important
one it is
this is national children's dental
health week and your dentist wants you
to know that children's first teeth are
important
they're necessary as guides for the
permanent witcher to follow protect your
children's first teeth
help your youngsters toward lifelong
dental health
for sparkling teeth and a lifetime of
dental health
start dental care early children who
begin proper dental care at an early age
form good dental habits that last a
lifetime
let your child enjoy lifetime devil
health
by starting proper dental care early
this message from the cleveland health
council
dental society presents
a good news story about dentures a
public service message about dental
health
first of all follow good dental
practices so you can keep your natural
teeth
as long as possible on the other hand if
you are unfortunate enough to have lost
your natural teeth
you can obtain substitutes one out of
four americans is already wearing
dentures but you'd never know it
modern dentures are so natural looking
lack of teeth
ages you hinders your digestion
handicaps you in many ways
careful study by your dentist is the
first step towards good looking dentures
that are functional and comfortable too
your dentures will be designed to meet
your personal needs with them you'll be
healthier
happier better looking you'll be your
same
not so old self once again for a better
life in every way
your dental society urges you to have
your teeth checked
regularly
your dental society in cooperation with
the american dental association presents
a tooth some tale the story of how man
has brushed his teeth down through the
ages
long ago toothbrushes were rather basic
then man began to depend on mother
nature
now we use small straight toothbrushes
two of them so one will always be dry
and fresh
brushing top teeth down bottom teeth up
and carefully cleaning the insides and
chewing surfaces most
important of all today smart people
brush their teeth immediately after
every meal
and when that's not convenient they
rinse their mouths with water
so for better dental health brush
properly and brush
immediately after meals with a good
toothbrush
this public service message has been
presented by your dental society
in cooperation with the american dental
association
these days everybody's talking about
reading about
and hearing about diets children
too need a well-balanced diet to promote
good general health as well as to
develop healthy teeth and gums
actually it's a simple diet every day
your child needs three glasses of milk
two or more servings of green or yellow
vegetables
two fresh fruits one raw including
citrus fruits
an egg and meat fish poultry or cheese
whole grain cereal and buttered bread
these are the foods your children need
to develop
strong healthy teeth they're good for
you too
to help prevent tooth decay substitute
fruits nuts and popcorn
for sweets between meals this has been a
public service message
presented to you by your dental society
and
the american dental association
introducing liz the quiz quiz she knows
all the answers in the category of
the importance of first tee so-called
baby teeth
do you
how many teeth in the first set liz 20
why are these first teeth so important
scientifically speaking the deciduous
medial and lateral and sizes
yes liz first teeth are important
because they maintain space for your
permanent teeth
when do permanent or second teeth appear
the time of incisor
yes liz the first permanent teeth
usually six-year molars appeared about
six years of age
their loss handicaps a child permanently
children should have their first dental
checkup when they're two years old or
when they have all their first teeth
so they'll win one of the most important
prizes of all
sound healthy permanent teeth this
public service message has been brought
to you by your dental society
in cooperation with the american dental
association
for sam he's worried sam's a social
outcast
at work he's no sensation either even
though he's only 35
he loves good food but can't eat
properly
what sam's troubled dental disease has
robbed him of his teeth
those he has are okay but he just
doesn't have enough of them
with only six teeth sam can't chew food
well
result poor digestion poor nutrition
sam goes to his dentist for professional
advice
his dentist tells him he needs partial
dentures
now look at sam handsome personable
self-confidence sam
no digestion or nutrition troubles now
sam's partial dancers are comfortable
attractive
serviceable easy to get used to fact is
one out of four americans wears dentures
today
this message has been presented by your
dental society and the american dental
association
smile pretty everyone oh poor peggy
too bad parents neglect baby teeth
youngsters are so sensitive about
appearance
and neglected baby teeth can cause
permanent teeth to come in damaged and
irregular
give your child the gift of a happy
smile your child's first teeth
are important
hold it partner old villain tooth decay
is hiding out in your mouth
ready to attack your teeth cause
cavities every time you eat
here's your troubleshooting toothbrush
it sweeps away
food particles helps knock out tooth
decay remember partner
reach for your toothbrush after every
meal
meet susie brown who wins the prize for
her sparkling smile
but wait a trophy also goes to susie's
mother
mother started taking susie to the
dentist when she was only two
he made sure susie's permanent teeth
would grow in sound and straight
be like susie's mother help your child
to healthy teeth
funny how we sweat and slave over things
which
soon go out of style yet we neglect our
teeth
which with care and attention can last a
lifetime brush your teeth immediately
after eating
give them the regular care they need
smile your way through life
your teeth can last a lifetime
teenage tommy wins all gals with a
secret weapon
his pearly teeth and gleaming grin the
smart set knows too many sweets are for
squares
they cause cavities make you feel funny
about your looks so
snack on fresh fruit milk or nuts teens
with healthy teeth
really raped
this is billy billy is a little boy who
is always happy and healthy
and who always wears a big smile
everyone likes to see billy smile or he
has clean
white teeth but
one day not long ago billy noticed that
one of his teeth was loose
soon it was loose enough to pull out
without hurting
tonight you should place the tooth under
your pillow said his mother
and in the morning you might find a
surprise under your pillow
so that night billy placed the tooth
under his pillow
soon after falling asleep he began to
dream
and in his dream he saw his tooth
it was larger than a tooth really is and
it could
move and talk hello
it said i'm tommy tooth i just wanted to
say
goodbye why must you go away
billy asked tommy tooth setting him on
his knee
because you are growing up and you need
a big grown up tooth
tommy tooth answered since you were a
very little boy
i have helped you chew your food i have
stood straight in line
so you could speak clearly and have a
nice smile
but now i am no longer big enough to do
the job well
so a bigger tooth will soon fill the
space i am leaving
and i shall take a nice
long rest somewhere but before i go
let me warn you said tommy tooth
your new tooth must last you the rest of
your life
so take good care of it
for good health you should have meat
vegetables and fruits milk
and bread or cereal every day
be careful about what you eat and when
you eat it
for instance sweets eaten between meals
can spoil your appetite also
because they are sticky sweets cling to
your teeth and sweet foods that stick to
the teeth
can cause your teeth a lot of damage if
not cleaned off immediately
that is why you should clean your teeth
right after eating
if possible if you do not have your
toothbrush with you
when you're away from home eating an
apple will help clean your teeth and
apples
taste good too besides
apples and other fruits give you
vitamins and minerals and
lots of energy finally
you should have a dentist look at your
teeth regularly
if you do all of these things carefully
especially while you are growing up
you will keep your second teeth a long
long time
even as long as you live
but now you must go back to sleep or
rest is also important
goodbye said billy and thank you
i'll remember what you've told me and
with that
billy's dream ended and he went on
sleeping peacefully
the next morning instead of the tooth
under his pillow
he found a bright shiny coin billy
showed his mother the coin
and told her about the dream the dentist
has told you the same things before his
mother said
but now that tommy tooth told you in
your dream
you will remember better than ever and
do you know dilly
did remember
so
few sights so stir the heart of man
few opportunities so fire his
imagination
as yes the chance to be a
sidewalk superintendent for example
here comes henry j fortel on his way to
an important appointment
hey hey what's going on hey let me
through
oh they're fixing the fridge
say yeah that looks like a big mouth
with a tooth missing what i say it's the
matter henry
does that remind you of your own misi
but what's a missing tooth
you have more important things to think
about oh sure sure i have
to say why all of us there's only one
measly little stone missing out of that
great big bridge
glad you brought that up henry
gives us a chance to show off our newest
piece of equipment
the future scope future scope
well what for to foretell the future
naturally
here see what the future of this bridge
would be
if it weren't being fixed right now uh
what do i do
just dial to bridge and press the button
it's a big bridge but like you said just
one measly little stone is missing
hey hey look and the other stones are
moving
then the whole bridge is getting out of
shape
ouch huh
just one stone starting all that
that's what could happen if they didn't
do something about it
uh hey this future scope uh work on
people too
yes me maybe
uh could it show me uh five ten years
from now
uh like uh like charles boye maybe
darling come with me to the casper
go on try it i can hardly wait
there you have it portal henry
hey wait why it can't be
there must be some some mistake the
future scope
never makes mistakes a handsome guy like
me
uh-huh how could it happen that's gonna
happen to me
because i i lost one weasley tooth
henry your teeth are like a stone bridge
in many ways
durable meant to last a lifetime
but like the stones in the bridge your
teeth depend upon each other for support
lose one tooth and and i can be in for
trouble yes starting with children it's
wrong to ignore a missing tooth
when youngsters lose their first teeth
too early a space maintainer can prevent
their teeth from shifting
if this is not done the permanent teeth
can come in crooked or out of place
it can spoil a child's smile for life
so what about me we'll show you
grown-ups should have the missing tooth
replaced too with a bridge
if it is not replaced well just look
the other teeth may start drifting into
the empty space
these irregularly spaced teeth are
harder to clean
so it is easier to get cavities
and because the teeth don't come
together properly there's liable to be
gum and bone injury if you neglect it
there may be infection of the tissue
around the teeth
and eventually this could lead to the
loss of all your teeth
oh my truth
i never realized just letting one tooth
go
well why didn't somebody tell me
and somebody did i just remembered
my dentist that's what my important
appointment was
i'm like
henry's lucky he realized in time the
damage
just one missing tooth can do
how about you
uh
you